this life is a test everyone you're
being tested right now what are you
going to do now you're seeing this
you're seeing this Holocaust this
genocide happening what are you going to
do you're just going to remain silent
your silence is your complicitness in
this so God is testing you are you going
to be on the right side of history or
the wrong are you going to be in
Paradise at Hellfire are you going to be
with God or you going to be with the
Devil with the
Shayan
may Allah on Tiny knots from our tongue
expand for us our chest allow us to
speak the truth allow us to be alone in
this room without the influence of Shan
may Allah forgive us for any slips or
mistakes from ourselves from Shan may
Allah unite the um and allow us to be
pillars in doing so may Allah allow us
to influence the Muslim men to be men
again and may Allah allow us to be
leaders for the righteous Allah aalam
Alum welcome back to the realist podcast
in the with the not one two three but
the four
Muslims
aldah thank you so much for having us
here so today alhamdulillah we are
actually we are we are in the uh sh town
in
shwn or just shwn they they call it Shak
yeah but
you know why that is right why tell us
why yeah because if you go a little down
south you know we're spending money all
over the the world you know fighting all
of these uh you know pressing people and
stuff but you got our neighborhood here
in Chicago can use some remodeling and
people can uh take them from sleeping on
the streets into uh you know taking care
of and giving opportunities and fixing
up our neighborhoods but they care less
about fixing the problems in their own
backyard man yesterday after we finished
the podcast with Dr Sail Ahmed your
esteemed friend yes may Allah bless him
we finished the podcast and we were a
little bit hungry right we go outside
just to get some food we just hear p p
and we just pause and we just keep
walking to the car and we hear p p p
again all right bro we're going to go
back we're not going to get no pizza at
like 1: a.m. but alhamdulillah is it
actually that bad over here what do you
think someone that's lived here I mean
I've grew up here my whole life so it
depends it's like depends where you're
at
depends uh what time of night you're out
yeah right the sh usually come out uh
you know as wisdom why we should be in
at a certain hour also so uh I think
during the day it's good depending on
where you're at yeah and what
neighborhood and who you're with and
what environment you're with but I mean
Chicago is a nice nice city but I think
it's it's gotten a little bit uh chaotic
andc and the recent uh downturn of
events that everyone knows about you
know it's led to to a lot of hate that's
taken the life of the six-year-old
innocent boy M we had that recently yes
to jna Shah with ease and you know the
sister that was
attacked the hijabi sister in Texas
right MH so these events that are
happening you know it's a reminder to
ourselves to you know take care of our
women and children not let them outside
by themselves at night and in dangerous
places but with this being said how was
your initial reaction when October 7th
happened
I
mean
when the whole situation with what's
going on in uh
Palestine Subhan
Allah it was it was something that
obviously as
Muslims you know just making a a
disclaimer here that anytime you know on
any side if you have innocent life being
taken we're we're against this obviously
but you know when we had this situation
where there's I mean obviously I didn't
know really much was going on but it
just had me go back into really
investigating and looking into you know
some of the things that were happening
and you had this whole thing with the
the 40 babies heads and you had so much
uh what they call atrocity propaganda
being pushed out and I was like man how
are people swallowing this how are
people you know really are they that
that naive and these things started to
out um and it seemed like all over again
you had post 911 all this people that
you were thinking that were more
aligning and going towards connecting
more with this the values of Muslims and
they were seeing the whole fight against
the alphabet movement and you know
destroy of the destruction of uh the
family values and whatnot uh trying to
change men into women women into men and
all this you know 10 and some genders
now and many Christians were seeing like
hold on man the Muslims are holding
strong and we had just came back from uh
doing um an event with uh the pbd
podcast with Patrick bavid I don't know
if you heard of him and I was really uh
elated to see how he himself and one of
his other guests certain Charlie Kirk
and they were like hold on we don't we
don't um even with all this mis
misinformation that they've been fed and
they kind of also regurgitate and they
put out there and and I really strongly
feel if they sit and talk with us not
talk about us but talk with us right and
not repeat a lot of the same talking
points from old or or uh haters of Islam
and islamophobia just repeating this
stuff I don't know if it's because
they're they're PID you know they this
is get them more views and clicks and
whatnot but Patrick uh David who I met
and he seemed you know very balanced
when we do when we did the um the
program he he brought me out and and
brother Daniel and Jake and went out
there and and it and it it turned out
pretty good and alhamdulillah then this
whole this everything that just happened
and then it was like hold on it's like
all this other everything like went out
the window it was like things started to
come to surface again this hate and you
mentioned the six-year-old uh Muslim boy
the young boy his landlord was building
him a treehouse and he was for two years
um he was almost like an uncle to him
right what and then they that's the
young boy one of the reports saying that
they he really like you know was nice to
his family and then all a sudden his
wife said that he had been listening to
conservative talk radio you know the
John Hann the Sean Hanes and the like
and these people pushing this pushing
this you know people are already on the
edge they don't know what the purpose of
life is they don't have peace and
contentment in their hearts you know
they're already like you know uh living
a a a stressed out anxiety filled life
and next thing you know boom they're
listening to much of this uh hate
propaganda and then next thing you go 40
babies and all this other stuff that's
like way out there it's been debunk CNN
came the person who got this stuff from
a from a from a a um
extreme settler and whatnot and then
they pulled back this was actually a lie
and then they took off with it then they
retracted the story and back and you
have people like Ben Shapiro keep
pushing this stuff they keep pushing it
fueling fueling and the guy snaps and
then he goes and kills 26 times he stabs
the young boy the mother got like I
think 11 times or something unimaginable
it's it's out of this world Power of
Words you know the power of um
so all this stuff um this is what upsets
me is you see many of these people who
are out there preaching you know love
love love and you know you know
beautiful teachings of Jesus peace be
upon them who we love and rever as one
of the mightiest Messengers you know
love your neighbors one of The
Commandments and this that but all of a
sudden all that stuff goes out the
window now when it comes down to uh you
know innocent uh lives babies being
literally blown up in
Palestine uh and these are Christians
also who are being attacked there and
oppressed so um and yeah so that's it's
it's out of this world I had no idea
that they had a civil relationship that
landlord and the sun yeah yeah they did
yeah he was their landlord it wasn't
some guy off the street a landlord and
he was renting to them and I was just
actually on the way to do a program with
um uh Ahmed rhab who's the when it when
it broke he's the care executive and he
was coming to see me we're about to film
an episode a program with him and he
said Eddie this just happened and then
he the press conference went to the and
we did he did the press conference I was
there and then the next day had the
janaza yeah
Allah Grant him Jenna and make easy for
his family and all them there
together it's funny uh and very ironic
because these are the same people that
will say that Islamic rhetoric is
violent and it entices people to
violence it calls people towards
violence and they can see in front of
their own eyes this this man who was
civil who was caring who was maybe even
loving to this young boy boy all of a
sudden in just a few words a few stories
one narrative switched up and committed
an insane act of violence it's it's sad
how deep the propaganda runs that when
let's be frank when a white man does
this it's like oh he's just mentally ill
he was a little it was a rough time for
him whatever whatever when a Muslim does
it it's always all their religion
entices them to do it you and me were
talking um actually all four of us were
just talking about how there are certain
narratives within uh the rabbi circles
and what they've been propagating and
they eles are calling for what seems to
be a complete genocide of the what they
believe to be the amalekites of today
and that doesn't just stop at
Palestinians it extends but let's just
focus on Palestine for now because
that's exactly what's happening they're
actually calling and they all a bunch of
them signed a petition to bomb I think
it was either a school or hospital or
something in Gaza they know children are
there they know Innocents are there they
know civilians are there who are injured
who can't leave or maybe in babies are
in incubators as I always love to say
but they're saying Rel religiously from
the Torah the way God commanded the
Believers at the time to kill the
amalekites and every trace of them even
the animals and the the the livestock
let's kill them in the same way why is
this narrative not being spoken about in
the same radical lens that they speak
about Islam with why do you think that
is yeah what we were talking about there
was um you it's when you make that that
contrast now when you have you have
Rabbi and I was asking you is this
something that you've that's kind of
coming out to the surface and and it's
good you make a contrast and you can see
like okay here when I when I was you
asked me in the beginning how you know
kind of because I always want to make
that framework people understand because
I'm always anticipating you have a lot
of people out there who are listening
and they don't know the whole thing of
the story they already been fed much of
the the hate propaganda and they're
thinking already Muslims are barbaric
are you know crazy and dehumanizing them
animals you know all this madness so
then we we show them on the framework
what really Islam is about and compare
like compare you look at even in times
of War it's prohibited to kill
non-combatants this is clear it's very
clear you know you can go from the Quran
killing one innocent human being as as
you kill the world saving one innocent
life as you say the world non-
combatants is to and then Prophet
Muhammad who is the last and final mess
sent to mankind peace and blessed be
upon him and all the prophets including
Jesus and Moses and all the ones uh that
came before him and you see that he also
gave instructions on not to kill
non-combatants women children which
we're seeing right now what is the
latest count I think it's like 4,000
children children these are I mean who
are literally being deated blowing up
bombs from the top cowards who are
pushing buttons you know they they come
out like men in face but they're just
pushing buttons and Bs are falling and
kids are just being annihilated just
it's it's horrific but then you have the
Zion
these RAB I who are now quoting
scripture in there I think this is what
you're referring to and they're talking
about and I didn't see this stuff before
but I don't know if they're getting
emboldened now and they're actually
discussing these verses that have no
mercy so Islam is showing Mercy yeah and
they're telling no mercy not even to the
donkey or to the horse or the cat let
alone the child or let alone the woman
let alone just anybody so now if you
contrast and you really see this I would
say this is my humble opinion and I've
checked with some people who are more
knowledgeable than myself on this I
would say this is one of the verses
that's been altered and changed because
you know the verse in the Quran where
God Almighty Allah is saying woe to
those who write the book with their
hands yeah and what P Price and what
gains they make by woe to them Allah is
talking about how they changed the text
they Chang the scripture that's why
Allah Allah God Almighty sent the last
and final messenger with the untampered
alter free authentic to Quran we have it
because Allah is just he's not going to
go ahead and allow this green light to
go killing innocent children what what
the cat do man absolutely what the
donkey do what is it right what the
child do I mean what I mean just you
know it's like a
mind-blowing and and now it becomes a
question of are they doing this for
religious purposes or are they using
religion as a cover up because we we'll
even say that extreme uh sects or groups
of Islam are not doing anything for
religious reasons they claim they're
doing it for religious reasons but
they're doing it for political reasons
now uh the reason I say this because
it's not just rabbis running with this
rhetoric it's it's it's it's congressmen
and women it's and I want to say that I
don't know if they actually have a
congress in in is or anything but like
it's it's the actual like State men and
women the officials themselves one
Israeli Ambassador it's the word I'm
looking for she said a child is a child
whether Palestinian or Israeli and
everyone all the other ambassadors
ambassadors were like yelling at her
another female Ambassador got up and
said that the children the Palestinian
children brought this upon themselves so
they have this rhetoric that a child
doesn't matter if they're Palestinian
it's their fault they're going to die
there have been many um slips and many
outright statements of people saying
this is not just a war on this is a war
on all the Palestinians this is on all
the civilians they use that that term
specifically on live air so now it's a
question of are they doing this because
they have a political goal or are they
doing this because they have a religious
goal is it not deeply rooted in relig
though I mean you have um you have
people who I've
interviewed from one side you know
people who I would consider friends like
M pilled uh he's an Israeli he's former
IDF you have Rabbi Weiss you have uh
Rabbi
Shapiro uh who actually held one of the
largest in I think it was in New York
Gathering of I think it was almost like
15,000 religious uh Jews rabbis anti
Jews right yeah so I always make that
disclaimer this is not a Muslim Jew
thing Muslims would love to Palestinians
would love to live in peace like they
were living during the time before yeah
the Z came there and started to occupy
and take over their lands but I don't I
just I usually ask anybody to put
themselves in this position how would
you feel someone is taking your land you
get you get upset if somebody's parking
in your parking lot right in your
driveway uh you'd freak out but let
alone someone coming to land grab and to
take so so now you have
people justifying I think people are
trying to use religion to try to justify
it's a convenient thing now and and I
often compare this like when you hear
this whole thing yes there was a certain
group of people at a certain time who
were
um the chosen people right chosen to
deliver a message to call people to the
pure monotheism to call people to be
morally upright uh not morally bankrupt
as as far as now these Injustice that
are going to so I think now people are
using I was thinking about this deeply I
how can a
people um act in a certain way uh who
are believers in God how it's it's a
it's a contra contradiction here so you
have people who like if you have this
entitled child you know right say a rich
entitled child how does he act he
becomes arrogant right so I think with
this whole thing like these are the
chosen people of of God you were at one
point yes you were it was a respon it
was it was an honor but a responsibility
you were given the responsibility you
didn't fulfill it and these were the
same people who now at the time of Moses
and this is another proof against people
who try to bring this because Islam
honors the people with the same
ethnicity right uh Moses we love Moses
he's mentioned more than any other
prophet in the Quran his Blessed Mother
mother Mary mamam she has a whole
chapter named after her blessed uh this
blessed woman in the Quran Jesus peace
be upon him who we love and Revere might
his mess he come from this from this
ethnicity right Prophet some of the
prophet's uh wives right I think it was
two right Sophia and U and um I think it
was two from this if I'm not mistaken
correct me if I'm wrong so again not a
Jewish Muslim thing but I think religion
is always used many times to try to J
ify certain things so you have one group
who was saying that we like Rabbi Weiss
and many of these Orthodox Jews that
these people are following not Moses's
teachings they're following the
teachings of theodo Herzel this is their
Prophet atheists communist these are
people who actually don't believe in God
so they're hiding behind religion wow
wow it's funny because they always say
that you know religion is used to
control the masses but and it's in its
like original form for the three main
religions it's not it's it's a spiritual
endeavor it's this is the truth this is
the way um but the people who use it to
control the masses are the the A-
religious people just trying to trick
the religious people so on that note um
my question is why do you think there's
a lot of Christians that are backing up
Zionism I think uh I just did a program
it was just um I took some notes here
and I think it's very very important he
this is a Pastor
Rick he he's in the 70s now he's very
well read very well learned and I asked
him this question
because I was thinking like wow I said
how could our Christian friends out
there who are and can we cannot have
blanket statements you know there's so
many Christians who are against this the
Palestinians themselves who are
Christian yeah they're the ones on their
backs this is happening uh they're
suffering the same as the the Muslim
Palestinians so he starts off with
talking about
how after post 911 and everything how he
was actually
convinced he was embarrassed to admit
you watch the program I did with him he
was embarrassed to admit that he fell
for a lot of this propaganda that was
pushed through the certain group they
were pushing this stuff out there trying
to divide Muslims and
Christians and and they would push this
stuff not only in the the movies with
the whole Boogeyman and the Muslims
coming to get you and this is why he's
saying by this particular
group and that was part of the agenda to
get us fighting with each other to
divide us and and Conquer that's how you
do it and then it was pushed in the
churches and then he goes even deeper
when I asked and I asked him um about
this skolfield Bible that he had talked
about before and if you'd like I can go
over some of the the notes that I think
this is very important it started off
with the first
phase that there was a man by the name
of John Nelson Darby this is in the
1830s he was an Anglican priest
and he became dissatisfied with the
church of England and he started his own
thing he moved to England and he in an
area Plymouth and then he had his little
congregation I believe it was called the
Plymouth uh Brethren Plymouth Brothers
he was collecting as the pastor was
explaining this history he was saying
that this man John Nelson Darby he was
collecting strange religious doctrines
things that were just far out there
extreme and he was connecting bits and
pieces and taking all this stuff and you
can imagine the kind of Frankenstein
stuff that's going to come together you
know the strangest of ideas and extreme
and he was putting all this stuff in a
bucket so then he compiled this
in phase two a man came along by the
name of scoffield cus scoffield Cyrus
scoffield came around and he met this
man was a con artist he was a cheat he
went to pres he went to prison for some
time for um for exactly what he was
called con man for conning people
cheating people this was now in the
1880s what happened when he got out of
jail he met the man who had known Darby
John Nelson Derby he he he knew uh this
he met this man who knew him and then
all of a sudden scoffield became a
DD a uh doctor in Divinity so scoffield
now Cyrus scoffield so he got he started
to go on different uh seminars teaching
teaching this stuff end of times
prophecies this new teachings that he
got and and and then what he decided to
do was he came up with this idea of
taking John Nelson Derby's teachings and
putting into the Bible wow and from
there he was broke he didn't have much
money so you got a man with idea but not
much money backing to do this after uh
some time the pastor was telling me that
he ended up getting invited to this
private club it was called called the
Lotus
club and this is only by invite it's not
something that you can just some of the
affluent very rich and as the pastor was
explained to me this was more this cost
more than he'd make in maybe even a year
it was it was that
highend and from there
it was a New York it was a a lawyer that
invited him to this it was either the
vice president or the president of a
zist organization this is where it
starts getting deep now so this same
lawyer he says Pastor Rick WS he talks
about how this lawyer was the one who
wrote the law passed in
1913 which gave the federal was part of
the Federal Banking Act so this lawyer
ends up
taking him to UK to uh England and he
arranges a meeting with the Oxford
publishing so he comes back now he's got
a contract now he's got funds he's got
money he's got
backing and now they're putting together
this scoffield
Bible and from there make a long story
short he puts this together and this
thing starts to slowly take off and it
didn't really take off too much until
the 1970s there was a book published
that called the um sold 40 million
copies it was called uh by hail Lindsay
the return it was called the the late
great planet Earth and in here it talked
about The Rebirth of Israel the threat
of war in the Middle East End Times
prophecies and one example of those this
prophecy uh is Jesus coming back twice
him coming back twice Jesus removing the
Christians taking him to heaven seven
years of tribulation and then the
Antichrist will attack Jews and Israel
and then Jesus Alam peace be upon will
come back to save
the so this is basically a zist Doctrine
which was made as Christian doctrine yep
so why this is important so important to
know because Christians
now many of our friends out there the
Patrick B Davids and the others who
we're trying to have relationships with
we have a lot in common uh from the
sexualization of the children to Family
Value we have so much in common so now
this comes up and they're seeing babies
being de in front of them but then
they're silent their mouths are shut
Jesus is preaching you know they're
calling the Prince of Peace we love
Jesus we say peace be upon him you got
people like Ben Shapiro who are saying
that he was a criminal and I don't want
I don't even want to say all the other
things that he says about Jesus but
you're that's your buddy Benny Benny's
your buddy now but Muslims are over here
saying that if you say anything bad
about Jesus you can get maybe a right
hook is
is we're not going to fly with it but
they're quiet they're silent and they're
seeing children being massacred because
now if they're a part of this haggy and
the Fox News and these type of
evangelicals who have been taught that
now it's sinful actually wow to
criticize this wow that this is
something a part of their Creed sounds
like something I know now you can see
why they're silent and why it's so
important to show them like this pastor
that I had on that this is fake prophecy
that they're trying to see instead of
letting the the the thing just come
naturally they're trying to fulfill it
forcefully and that's where you get
chaos that's where you get you know you
get all of these now they got
contradictions with them in themselves
they're seeing like hold on this is not
what Moses or Jesus will give a a green
light to the Moses came back Jesus they'
be they' be fighting against this so we
need to talk to also our Christian
friends and also others who are voting
for this stuff who are seeing where
their 4 million4 billion a year going
towards this this is not not a part of
their Creed this is fake prophecy fake
um fake doctrine that was put together
by a con man scoffield ISM which is
basically sism wow subh Allah and this
this is why it's so important to read
through the history to know how we got
to where we are I always talk about it
from the like Palestinian perspective um
why is even qu quote defending itself
against these people to begin with how
did we get here um and everything that
led up to this point but now from a
religious perspective it's it's more
important cuz what is religion it's
supposed to be inherently from God so if
you could trace it back to a man and
very not so upright man as you described
he was a con artist and
stuff um then I think it becomes clear
that it's not true if people care about
Truth for religion to begin with um and
I think that this is a good time to also
invite them to Islam uh because it's
like listen our tradition goes back to
the prophet Muhammad himself which we
always claim um well we also claim
obviously as a messenger from God and
there's evidence for that in give that
to them as well but for them more
importantly when you trace their lineage
back when you trace their um their uh
kind of suned their CH transmission back
doesn't go to God doesn't go to even
Paul doesn't go to definitely doesn't go
to Jesus or the disciples it goes
to S essentially or this this guy who
took these extreme views and threw them
all into one book and then corrupted the
Bible with it um because it's not like
they're reading the skull field Bible
today I think this is the the point want
to make they're not reading the
scoffield Bible today but they believe
in it without knowing this was see what
they did was they gave as P I mean this
is Pastor Rick my guest who I had on who
was explaining this he was saying they
gave over aund a million copies for free
they pushed this out for free and then
it then it took off in the churches and
they were preaching this in the churches
so this became just kind of normal and
then they intertwined it and this was
something in the in the in the footnotes
so I give it to you for example like if
you've heard of um this when we were
there in um the the the debate of the
year you can call it U with the uh
Spencer
guy he has his own tapir you know that
right critical he has his own he's
someone who's Islam hater and he's
actually made a t he's actually given ex
aesus of the Quran he's saying this
verse and this is what it
means I mean it's not technically teer
like the cat or whatnot but he's
actually given explanation to verses how
they should be can you imagine now
following someone like that who's an
extremist who's somebody who was on the
uh Andrew brevi I believe it was um this
Manifesto and he's somebody who is if
you would read the way he's interpreting
certain verses from the Quran you would
think okay that would probably entice
you to go do something that you
shouldn't be do where over here you have
the consensus of Muslims telling you
this is how it is right so now so now if
you here's my point here's the example
I'm trying to give so if you take his
interpretation of something is going to
lead you a certain way so now you have
scopio Bible study Bible and then you
have certain verses and then you have in
the footnotes is explaining to you that
verse and now can they're connecting it
and giving the ex interpretation to it
you get it you know what's crazy though
yeah is that they package it in a
Feelgood message mhm so perhaps maybe
even the pastors that are spitting this
they're regurgitating it perhaps they
don't even know what it is right and
then for them they're just trying to
make into this few good message I'm sure
you've seen the pastors when they are
giving the message of the the gospel the
Bible and all that stuff they're they're
they're passionate about it right so you
have these people who are listening and
let's be honest most people nowadays are
easily influenced so if you have someone
who's speaking passionately about
something and it's making you feel good
as you're hearing
it it's it's a no-brainer that you're
going to be influenced by this yeah
something that just kind of crossed my
mind is the origin of this so you
mentioned that there was a derby was a
person who collected all the crazy views
and then put them into one place so for
me that sounds like it was a kind of a
half half like deranged man just taking
all the crazy stuff throwing into a book
I think it might I haven't researched
obviously but it might even be more
probable that he took the extreme views
that fit with whatever narrative he
liked or he wanted and to tie this into
kind of the geopolitical realm I think
that in light of World War I uh post
World War I where the Muslims were
defeated they knew that the Muslims had
a strong history of being dominant when
they're United and all this stuff and um
maybe this might be a stretch but even
kind of um know I'm not I won't go that
far let me keep it simple inshallah
so now from a geopolitical perspective
yeah I don't want to I I tend to to rent
too much I don't want to go down there
so to simple inshallah um I think they
are looking at the Muslims as some kind
of a threat and that's why they divided
the Middle East to different countries
and all that stuff so it could even be
possible that they created this
Narrative of Zion of reining Israel
because they know where it is and they
know if they fund it that they will be
basically with them uh to fulfill their
National interest and this is still
rhetoric that we hear regurgitated today
like Joe Biden said maybe a decade ago
or so that if there was no Israel would
have to invent in Israel that it's the
greatest investment for America so
knowing that these are westerners who
infiltrated Christianity and and and
pushed and got funding for I think
that's a big part they got funding for
this message actually had a political
Endeavor on the back end that we need to
keep America Britain Western countries
on the top and keep the Muslims kind of
snuffed out do you think when you were
speaking to um to your guest do you
think that that would fit in his his
understanding of the situation yeah he
talked a lot about control
manipulation um so he he I think more
people should um should listen to this
and I think that um you guys should have
him on I think he's uh he's very well
versed in this area I think it's very
and you have Christians like this like
that who
uh we opened up the program talking
about him he we know this history but
hearing it from a Christian he was
talking about when Muslims conquered
Jerusalem so the pastor is talking to
his other co-host Christian co-host and
he's narrating the story about Muslims
conquering coming into Jerusalem and
then them actually for hundreds of years
8900 years how many being in charge of
the key for the churches they're
protecting the churches so now now what
you're seeing so that's why it's
important to study history and then you
have I've had the rabbis come on and
talk about how Jews Christians Muslim
how we were living in Palestine they
were living in peace there was uh there
wasn't all this chaos and when the
Muslims even the Ottomans when they were
in charge for how many 400 plus years
there wasn't this chaos now this in the
Middle East with all of this there was
actually the Jews were given their
rights this is actually embedded this is
ingrained in the
God's laws this is you can't take that
away it's not like something that today
it's one way and then next thing you
they make an amendment and all your
rights are gone no it's instilled it's
embedded in there it's for the Christian
and for Jews so this Pastor Rick is
talking about how for hundreds of years
800 the Muslims had the keys this was a
symbol now they were in charge there and
the churches were protected let alone
right now these churches are also being
bombed yeah MOS are being bombed it's
like militants in there bomb
oh Hospital mil bom it doesn't it just
doesn't make any sense it's like saying
okay you got a school shooter and now
there's a thousand kids in Auditorium
and now we're going to get the shooter
but now okay press the button and throw
everybody everybody make any sense yeah
no not at all it doesn't it doesn't make
any sense but again it goes back to you
know many people who are voting for this
and whatnot like the um like the
politicians and the Ted Cruz and all
these guys and Who quote different Bible
verses and say those who you know um uh
bless and they'll put this particular
movement in there they're blessed and
who who cursed so they think it's a
sinful act but now it's very important
other Christians like Pastor Rick are
coming out say no this has nothing to do
with our theology our Creed they've been
actually they've been conned they've
been fooled they've been duped because
they're more involved in politics than
the religion they're more involved in
politic that's their religion yeah their
religion in connection to Jesus is zero
right they use it as is a scapegoat yeah
right and it's just like those guys who
Jesus turned over and started whipping
them because they are in the churches
you know doing the riba and the interest
and whatnot and and then those people
now who are who are backing this kind of
behavior is disgusting this is why I
love human psychology and if you're just
patient and You observe People review
everything yeah you know like these
politicians I'm not going to say
anything about them
but they say everything about themselves
give them enough time they'll say
everything yeah let me ask you this uh I
was listening to one of them are there
you live in France now are there no go
like Muslim no gold zones in France
where people can't go if they're not
Muslim I thought this was totally absurd
like that there's this is a lie but you
can tell me zes no no no you probably
let me rephrase it that if there's
Muslim neighborhoods that you can you
cannot go in there unless you're Muslim
like Muslims have put up Muslims have
Muslims have made in UK and also in
France that neighborhoods where only
Muslims can go like a holy site yeah
like almost I listen I don't know if
that's in France I know in UK they may
have something like this but in France
if they do have it it could possibly be
in like bigger cities that's not true no
but I would I would I would object to
100% no Muslims are saying come to our
neighborhoods come eat with us come you
misunderstood me you misunderstood me no
he they're saying these are no go zones
there's nothing like that no France even
in the UK in the most Sharia I'm talking
like in the Islamic Republic of burm
then you find it there no guarantee you
okay because the politicians you have
they were on the pbd podcast the one uh
he's saying that now there are no goal
zones but this they repeat this stuff on
these hanity news stations and many
these Fox stations so the average
American is like hold on what are these
guys up to there's places we can't even
go but see they're projecting the the
see these groups are projecting this
stuff onto US they're making the people
who are at most peace in their lives
with their creator with their neighbors
who are people of Peace Muslims are
people of Peace people I know what Islam
did for me you also have come to Islam
you guys that made at one point the
decision to actually be Muslims once who
submitted to the world go you know what
Islam does for you it doesn't call you
to be extreme radical doing something
crazy fanatical cause you to be at peace
with your cat the one and only one God
to be morally upright and to be good to
your neighbors no matter if they're Jew
or Christian doesn't matter we're not
people of trying to you know hate
someone because he's Jew or that's not
what our religion teaches but they're
trying to push that out to the masses
but actually cities they have no gold
zones it's not just me saying this is
Israelis the millets and the rabbi Weiss
said these are people who tell you the
they actually have areas that you cannot
go if you're someone who's not Muslim
you have athid state you have um you
someone who's probably more qualified
you know about this apartheid where the
right of return for for example yeah you
know somebody who's lived in this land
his gener his family's lived this his
land generation and generations now they
don't have a right to come back but
someone in Bronx New York Brooklyn in
the city of New Jersey can go ahead
never visited never been there but they
can come and you know have free fall
free ticket free everything and they can
get a citizenship does that make sense
not at all two sets of law for two
different people so palestin Muslims are
not against Jews Christians or any other
you have live your religion go ahead God
will judge you at the end we want to
invite you to Islam of course but at the
end of the day nobody is for stealing
land stealing homes and this is what's
happened plain and simple no one in
America would none of these politicians
these guys who are out there signing
these bills letting them go would they
be okay with someone just taking over
their their park their their driveway
let alone throwing them in the basement
live there and then putting checkpoints
in the house makes no sense absolutely
bro this is why it's so important that
people not not go to the mainstream
media for the news they need to actually
research look at the history look at
what happened look at what's actually
going on because if they look at
mainstream media if they listen to the
politicians all they're going to get is
a twisted narrative yeah and they're
never going to know the truth yeah um
just like Dr seil mentioned he said 75%
of people who uh he mentioned a stat
from a group of people who basically
hate Muslims think they're extremists
75% of them have never met a Muslim
right um now the from that percentage or
from that group only 28% of them once
basically from those who meet Muslims
retain that belief that they're crazy or
whatever so most people once they
actually meet a Muslim they they like oh
they're chill people they're normal
people that's this the point I was going
to make before if they if these people
actually only knew what Muslims really
believed and thought they would love to
live beside a Muslim they would love to
eat with Muslims and sit with Muslim
they would love to trust the Muslims
with their money more than the bank
CU they know that the bank's going to
use it to lend it out to people and if
they go bankrupt it's like sorry you
lose 80% of your money you can only get
20% back with a Muslim it'll be safe
it'll be in a safe place no one will
touch it they won't even touch it and
you'll get it back whenever you want why
why is it that as Muslims we would do
something like that it's because Allah
one he instructed us to two we know if
we disobey God we're doing more of an
injustice against ourselves three the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
himself as the best example for us his
not just you know non-muslim his enemies
people who actually wanted to kill him
gave their gold and their treasure to
him to hold knowing that he's he's such
a good man even though we want to kill
him he's not going to you know steal our
wealth I like what you said right there
this is an important verse that's
actually in Harvard University they have
this up on the wall this verse about
Justice and they quoted a verse from the
Quran yeah that being uh that holding to
Justice even if be against yourselves
your family no matter what so this is
this is us this is the history of Islam
this is something that you know even for
for my my children if I was seeing them
you if Muslims are teaching their
children to hate a certain ethnicity a
certain group if I heard my children my
own children talk like that smack them
upside the head you know what I'm saying
because that's not just yeah you judge
individual by the individual and if that
individual is having these extreme
Tendencies and whatnot then obviously
that's something that we're against
stealing homes stealing lands stealing
these kind of course what human being
that's that's the hypocrisy that we got
to call out and this is something that
you know when you see it when you see it
with and this is what's s hopefully this
can awaken many of many of our neighbors
and people out there just get the whole
picture and many of them just misled
they get have because if you're it's a
programming that's going on but that's
the interesting thing you don't believe
everything when it comes to Trump for
example you like fake news fake news
fake News why you believing it here now
why you believing it here you're not giv
the whole picture so get the whole
picture come to a m visit with a Muslim
talk to a Muslim a Muslim is one who
simply does like what Jesus I always
defined these words submits his or her
will to the cre heavens and earth he
could be American he could be Italian he
could be polish he can be like our
brother here Latino he can be uh from
Bangladesh he can be from uh Palestine
right it's a universal way of life
worshiping God being morally upright
that was a wonderful point before we
wrap up I do want to ask you a question
as Muslims today living in the west the
average Muslim today what can we do to
actually help and make a difference
because you know there's a blockade a
lot of these you know fundraisers and
and Islamic relief and all this money is
actually not being able to be sent right
now so what can we do as average Muslims
today in the west I mean I was watching
um I was watching and I think um this is
something really important they had this
uh MMA this kind of washed up uh MMA guy
he's uh also with this extreme ideology
he's uh yeah I've seen him he's he has
and he put the khabib's name on he put
the Hamza chai
mammad and a now imagine if that was
flipped imagine that was flipped now so
he takes these men who have nothing to
do they're just Muslim no uh and they
might have said something that now is in
support um for or disapproval of the
mass ethnic cleansing the Muslim
genocide that's happening now I don't
know but he's over
here instead of being man enough in
their face he puts a picture and he puts
the their names on a what does that
signify what message does that sent now
what is that just hate it's just hate
it's hatef so the point here is that's
he's not looking at his Meb he's not
looking at his you know difference of
opinion on some fi matters or whatnot
he's after them all so that's one thing
for us to be United to see that now
there's no disc they're not
discriminating if they're going to come
against
you him this person that person so uh it
should be they've United in hate let us
unite in love love for each other we
give each other peace peace be with you
and we make Dua that Allah unites our
hearts because when that b hits It's not
distinguishing just like this guy from
this uh MMA fighter who put the names of
khabib and hamat and whatnot that's the
same day we're looking at you and live
Islam live our live our Dean when you
see in Gaza and Palestine this is
another thing I I I spoke about was that
you see a lot of non-muslims not yet
Muslims out there and they and it
reminded me of the verse where God
Almighty Allah the Creator and the
verbaan word of God he Allah is saying
they part and plan Allah plans Allah is
the best of planners the Creator is the
best of planners so you're seeing these
Nota Muslims they seeing like the the
people out there
houses
hospitals just getting annihilated
bombed children just just being just
shelters um being decapitated from these
bombs but they're saying alhamdulillah
Subhan Allah they're making Salah
they're still praying they're still
connected to their creator strong what
about usse here nagging
complaining not making Salat abandoning
our Dean so this should be also
something that another wisdom that we
can go ahead and then those those not
those Nota Muslims they're looking at it
they're like I want to read They're
they're they want to see what is
inspiring these people to be one is
saying I haven't seen one of them curse
the Jews look at not one I've seen in
all this even cursing Jews the other one
I haven't seen them just say they're
saying alhamdulillah they're praising
have you seen these videos have you seen
those you seen that so this is amazing
so there's so much reflection deep
reflection for us for ourselves so many
lessons that we can take from this AB
the main one is to hold on to our Dean
and try our best not to be divided
there's there's actually a big movement
I think on Tik Tok a lot of people
reading the Quran even publicly on live
for the first time um just being
inspired by these people Subhan Allah so
my next question is what do you think
the obligation upon Muslims are or would
be in in times like this what can the
Muslims do or what do the Muslims have
to do to show these misinformed people
that we're not actually these extremists
use your social media platforms you know
no share if you don't know share if you
care you share um talk to your friends
talk to your
neighbors and educate them education is
key you know educate um ignorance is is
something that's leading a lot of people
to make a lot of the decisions that
we're making that's why I really wanted
to to discuss some of this um to talk
about what I just what I was just blown
away by the Pastor Rick who was
discussing this and just by this I think
sometimes when people get to learn like
they've been lied to once twice and I
think you made a good point like you're
going to continue being lied to and
trying to figure out out where the LIE
began and anything when you come to
something pristine something like the
Quran where these people are looking at
they they open up uh and you have these
videos they they open up the Quran and
it's not like the lady's relaying she's
like it's not like once upon a time uh
when it came to pass she's like the
Quran just gets straight into it yeah
tells you how it is because this is from
the creator of the heavens and earth
this is from God Almighty Allah so um
just um
sharing doing our obligation of dawa
getting out there educating our friends
neighbors and colleagues on what the
true purpose of life is connecting them
trying to be a bridge connecting them
towards their creator and speaking on
behalf of the voiceless they're
voiceless now and this the tide is
beginning to shift and turn because
people are seeing and we asked them just
to put themselves in their shoes someone
came to take your apartment someone gave
you a ticket unjustly someone pulled you
over unjustly we got the people go up in
in all hell breaks loose you got the
George Floyd Boom everybody the whole
country and everything but imagine if
some of these things that's happening to
75 years of Oppression 75 years hey man
can you imagine yeah put yourself in
their shoes share a documentary share
something Andy try to remove the
ignorance and and pray keep your your
connections with Allah strong with your
creator strong you made an amazing point
and this is something that I wanted to
say ear I completely forgot
about they they have this idea of like
deep down that it's okay cuz it's
happening to to to Muslims or like they
have the humanized Muslims are to the
point where when they hear 75 years of
illegal occupation and and Corruption
and just murder ethnic for these people
some of them it literally means nothing
to them so when they hear these people
Revolt they still think they're evil so
I like the point you made because you
can go back into American history the
American Revolution that was very bloody
Civil Wars those were very bloody the
this the slave revolution where the
slaves revolted that was very
bloody and the even you know breaking
from the Catholic church and the start
of secularism that was very bloody they
see all these things as good because it
led people to a better place so now when
you have the Muslims doing the same
exact thing why is it that they Ukraine
right now is doing the same thing
revolting against Russia fighting back
against Russia because they invaded and
whatever whatever why is it now that
when the Muslims do it the Arabs do it
it's not acceptable you have to force
them to deal with this deeply rooted uh
ignorant perception of Muslims and this
deep belief that they might have that
Muslims actually deserve it to an extent
and I think that's very uncomfortable
for people but some of them I think you
need to push them to that point I like
the example you gave of Ukraine this is
just a perfect example right there so
these now people who are resisting
Freedom Fighters everything is okay
right and we're not talking about and
then the whole argument uh human shield
and all these other things that come up
you know who gave a beautiful example
and I get impressed really when I see
people who are connected their families
connected to Holocaust this is something
Islam condemns Norman felstein yeah yeah
have you guys had him on no yeah I
invited him but he Norman finlin he's a
Jewish Professor he was here in Chicago
I believe in depal if I'm not mistaken
he destroyed this Swan Zionist um in a
debate um I forgot what his name was
dtz and he ended up going after him he
got I think he got him fired anyways cuz
he called him on on plagiarism and a
bunch of other things long story short
when he was asked this question about
this human Shields he said okay we're
not going to because this is one of the
common arguments that you hear yeah and
again it's another projection of what
one side of one group of people are
doing and now they're putting it on this
group of people so he said we're not
going to take what the resistance is
saying and we're not going to say what
the the is saying we're going to look at
the human rights organizations and he's
been 40 years Norman I advise the
audience to go Norman finlin 40 years
he's been cover he's a Jewish Jewish man
academic so he looks at he starts off
with okay let's look at the the human
rights organization in Israel what do
they say about this human shield what do
they say about all this amnesty what do
they say uh and all he lists
un investigation he lists a whole list
of them MH and then he's like actually
there's no evidence for it yeah he says
he flip he flips it he says actually
they're the ones yeah who are actually
using Palestinians as human Shields I'm
like BL wow yeah yeah yeah specifically
on on the point Amnesty International he
mentioned that Amnesty International has
a a document titled I think 22 days of
death and D destruction on operation
castled and and that he said exactly
that or amesty International reported
exactly that Not only was there no
evidence of Hamas using human Shields
but they had evidence of Israel the IDF
using Palestinians only as human Shields
to the point where they would put them
up in a window put the barrel of the gun
over the Palestinian shoulder and from
over their heads and put them on on the
front of Tanks they would put them uh in
on the on the on the front of cars so
you know Hamas or whoever you know
wouldn't want to blow up because even
they know to an a certain extent h says
is more moral than them they won't even
blow up their enemy if you know innocent
people are there Subhan Allah but I
don't think if anybody here if I asked
anybody if you are paying membership to
a certain organization or you're part of
you know any of the honestly I was like
when you hear ham Hamas you know ham
much that we eat I I don't know hon I
don't know these groups and whatnot all
I see is and this is the voice that I
try to put out there is when you see
children innocent children when you see
uh I just spoke to I sent a message to
Arnold S
I saw Arnold Schwarzenegger he put out
an anti-hate message good for you Arnold
Schwarzenegger and then he also was
asked about Israel and Palestine and he
was like I'm 100% with Israel and this
that and the other but and then he goes
on and I'm like hold on this is great
Arnold anti-hate and then he went to
owitz visited the the um the camps and
whatnot good we're against it we're on
the same page but then I'm asking them
but hold on Arnold like are you scared
of getting canceled or what not you see
what's H this is never again but we're
seeing right now we're seeing a a
Palestinian Holocaust happening right
now this is unfolding right in front of
our very eyes it's like live 4K I mean
you're seeing it so Arnold did you never
again accept the Palestinians I mean
that's the thing I don't understand it
doesn't make any sense yeah that's a
great point and I think for and I have a
similar example with jus and Trudeau I
don't know if you saw the video yeah he
put out the the uh video or the picture
of Ash goaz getting bom no Justin
Trudeau I'm thinking about Justin Bieber
Justin Bieber did that listen man
they're both they're both Canadians both
yeah yeah you're right Justin Bieber and
then he retracted didn't say anything
Jam Lee Curtis put Palestinian children
basically looking up the sky scared a
bomb and hit them and said pray for
Israel she deleted it um Justin Trudeau
was at a press conference and it's it's
it's it's sad when you see the humanity
try and come through and then it's
halted by something
we'll talk about what that something is
in a second but he was saying we need to
see a ceas and then he's like he
couldn't repe I saw that yeah he
couldn't repeat it he was just like
stumbling mumbling and cuz they're
scared of being cancelled they're scared
of saying certain things now the bosses
who push the buttons and give the
paychecks who Endor the campaigns yeah
they're not going to go ahead they're
going to get cancelled money will be
withheld and whatnot yeah absolutely
it's disgusting disgusting and the thing
I often think of I think this is a test
for everybody we're this is and this is
exactly what the the Quran God Almighty
Allah is saying that this life is a test
so everyone you're being tested right
now and what are you going to do now
you're seeing this you're seeing this
Holocaust this gen happening what are
you going to do you're just going to
remain silent and your silence is your
complicitness in this yes so God is
testing you yeah are you going to be on
the right side of history or the wrong
are you going to be in Paradise at
Hellfire are you going to be with God or
you going to be with the Devil with the
Shayan yeah you make an amazing point
because um subh Allah I guess to link
this to Islam Allah he does say in the
Quran this is specifically for the
Muslims that he will he will test you uh
to see who is a True Believer you know
to see who's really a True Believer
Allah subhana tala he already knows who
a True Believer is and isn't he just
knows deep you know deep down within us
who isn't isn't the reason he tests us
is so he can show us that's the whole
reason for this life so we can build a
case for or against ourselves in the day
of judgment so we can't just wake up and
God says you're going to hell and we're
like why that doesn't make sense so on
top of that we can also see with the
non-muslims who actually stands for
their values or not international law at
the very least at the bottom level of
all this international law is being
violated if there's one thing that
American politicians should stand behind
it's the law and if you can't stand
behind the law what do you stand for war
crimes are being committed international
law is being violated time and time
again and America's funding the country
that's doing it time and time again so
we can see some Muslims if they are
really who they say they are if they
really believe in Islam preach Islam or
if they have alterior motives but we can
also see what the non-muslims you know
Christians Jews do they really believe
in what they say they do or are they
going to turn their back and become of
their own religion all of the sudden of
their own laws absolutely hypocrisy yep
the biggest levels yeah may Allah keep
us steadfast keep us forgive us for our
shortcomings make us righteous and
leaders for the
righteous um do we have more time do we
have to ask W up I think we got a
session with the de show we got a
session with the show too Eddie in the
meantime you know where can we find more
of you any of the viewers watching uh
people can go to the Deen show.com and
we can go ahead and um get them if
they're not yet Muslim out there if they
like a free copy of the Quran to look
for yourself to look does Islam promote
terrorism does Islam promote violence
what does Islam say what's the main
message what's it say about Jesus what
does it say about purpose of life the
deta of Life Hereafter Hellfire par
everything that you want the Encompass
manual for Life we'll get it to you for
free at theen show.com
amazing may Allah reward you guys
for any final words from you guys yeah I
just wanted to give a huge shout out to
uh the rest of the crew over here behind
the camera that no one can see right now
uh your work does not go unnoticed may
Allah bless you guys and until next
time everyone for tuning in may Allah
bless all mentally please share this
because we have for the first time in
person our brother Eddie from the dean
show share with everyone like comment
subscribe make sure to get the message
out and we'll see you guys on the next
one